أعتقد أن ريسي تصدر ، وأعتقد أنه
في الماضي كانت هناك انتخابات مُعدَّلة دائمًا تقريبًا ،
كان عام 2009 هو الأكثر شهرة ، لكني
لا أعتقد أنه كانت هناك
انتخابات تم
تصنيعها بشكل واضح لإنشاء السيد ريسي
للقضاء على أي شخص يمكن أن يكون محتملاً.
تقديم أي
تحدٍ له ومحاذاة
ما سيأتي بعد ذلك سواء كانت الرئاسة فقط
أو ما إذا كانوا في الواقع يهيئون له
ليكون خليفة الانسجام الذي أعتقد أنه
لا يزال يتعين رؤيته ولكنه أمر تبعي للغاية
ولكنه أيضًا عميق.  انتخابات هزلية
آخر انتخابات لاحقة كانت عام 1997
عندما فاجأ على الأقل
الإيرانيين أه أه تعرف
الطبقة السياسية على حين غرة ، الإصلاح
فاز الرئيس خاتمي
ورأينا بعض الاختلافات الفعلية التي
سُنت إلى حد ما
أخبر الناس الذين لم يسمعوا
بإبراهيم من قبل  حق الرهيسي ، انظر إلى
من هو ولماذا يهم وماذا
يعني إذا كان
النظام بأكمله مغلفًا الآن في
السلطة المحافظة المتشددة التي
أراها كانت موجودة
القضاء طوال
حياته المهنية التي قضاها منذ ما يقرب من 40
عامًا
، لقد كان كل شيء من مدع عام
إلى رئيس القضاء
، وهو الأكثر شهرة لكونه جزءًا
من فريق من أربعة
أه ما يسمى قضاة أرسلوا حوالي أربعة
آلاف شخص
داخل  فترة ثلاثة أشهر حتى
وفاتهم على بابا سمين عند الله الخميني ،
هؤلاء كانوا أشخاصًا يقضون وقتًا
في السجن بالفعل ،
وهناك عدد قليل جدًا من القضاة الذين لديهم
ماضي غامق مثله ، ولست متأكدًا من أنه يستطيع
السفر إلى كثيرين  دول في العالم
لأنه
قد تكون هناك إجراءات أه
ضده بالتأكيد اتهم من
قبل الشخص الذي تم تعيينه
لخلافة آية الله الخميني السيد منتظيري
كمجرم اتصل به في
اجتماع شريط الاجتماع موجود
يقول أنك أحضرته  عار على هذا
النظام ، لقد جلبت العار إلى الإسلام ، لذا
فهو سيء السمعة بقدر ما يمكنك الحصول عليه ، لكنه
سهل
الانقياد ، جندي من الانسجام وأعتقد
أن هذا هو سبب اختيارهم له ،
إنه محافظ للغاية كما تقترح
sted وهو
أيضًا مستعد جدًا لاستخدام القوة
لقمع
النسب وهو مناهض
للغرب إلى حد كبير ، إنه في معسكر
يحاول إنشاء
المزيد من العقارات الإسلامية وأقل بكثير
من جمهورية إسلامية